bonsoir à tous le 22 septembre va être
un grand jour pour moi c'est le jour de
sortie de mon premier roman édité par
une grande maison d'édition
vous pouvez penser que ces jeunes de
sortir un roman à 16 ans alors je passe
mon bac de français à la fin de l'année
toujours est il que ça fait un moment
que cette histoire a commencé j'avais 11
ans et on m'a mis entre les mains
sept romans que vous connaissez
certainement la saga harry potter
j'ai lu pendant dix jours jours et nuits
ses romans les cachant sous mon lit à
fois que mes parents ne me les
confisquent baca koné c'est la cantine
il est l'heure de dormir tuer l'école
demain lorsque j'ai tourné la dernière
page dari ma passion pour la littérature
était né et j'ai enchaîné avec une
quantité astronomique de livres
best-seller de littérature jeunesse
j'ai même commencé à écrire un peu dans
mon coin mais ce qui a vraiment changé
le cours de ma vie c'est cette annonce
dénicher un jour dans le journal de
mickey dont je suis un fervent lecteur
ont proposé de devenir jurée pour le
grand prix des lecteurs du journal de
mickey
alors le principe était très simple
rédiger quelques critiques qui
paraîtrait ensuite dans les pages de ce
journal est à terme choisir avec les
sept autres jurés le roman jeunesse de
l'année la veille de la clôture des
candidatures
j'ai rédigé une petite critique comme
demandé que j'ai posté le lendemain
matin en me rendant à l'école cachet de
la poste faisant foi
deux mois plus tard en voiture avec ma
maman
celle ci reçoit un appel et me demandent
de l'écouté pour elle cette messagerie
vocale et là j'apprends que je suis pris
des marins signé mon travail de critique
littéraire quatre mois à lire des
oeuvres quatre mois donné mon avis
dessus et quatre mois pendant lesquels
j'ai fait la connaissance de camier qui
allait devenir ma meilleure amie elle
aussi passionnée par la littérature
et puis quand ce grand prix c'est
terminé on s'est rendu compte que tout
allait s'arrêter dans tout imaginer que
la chose qui perce votre vie et je parle
pas de l'école s'arrête d'un claquement
de doigts
ainsi on s'est dit pourquoi ne pas
continuer à rédiger des critiques
ensemble on avait plus journal de mickey
on n'avait pas envie de lancer un blog
parce qu'on voulait pas faire que
monde à l'époque alors on s'est dit on
va lancer un magazine sur internet comme
le journal de mickey mais en numérique
et nous mêmes mais pour cela il nous
fallait un nom c'est là que je me suis
souvenu d'un journal un contest avec
quelques copains en classe à l'époque ma
maîtresse avait demandé à ma classe de
cm1 de réaliser la une d'un journal et
mes potes et moi avions tellement qui
fait le boulot qu'on avait continué à
faire ce journal et on l'avait publié à
une trentaine d'exemplaires
il faisait à peu près six pages il
sortait toutes les semaines et on a
publié comme ça des sept numéros on
avait neuf ans et notre journal
s'appelait le petit mardi alors avec
camille quand il a fallu relancer un
magazine sur internet on s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas faire un peu de
nostalgie et puis reprendre ce nous sur
ce le petit mort dix années mais il nous
fallait aussi une structure quelque
chose d'un peu plus contre et concret
est passé le numérique
alors on s'est dit et je me suis surtout
dit je vais monter ma maison d'édition
alors l'idée paraît un peu compliquée
sur le sur le mot sur le coup surtout
que voilà il est monté une entreprise
les avait 14 ans j'étais mineure c'est
un peu compliqué sur ce je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas utiliser mes parents
comme prête-nom ça s'est fait un peu
simplement en quelques jours
l'association a été créée avec un
capital de départ assez simple les 100
euros d'économies qui lui restait dans
la tirelire et qui éprouvait la plupart
du porte-monnaie de mes grands parents
le petit mardi a perduré pendant quatre
ans il ya eu en tout une soixantaine de
numéros qui ont une tous étaient
rédigées par des adolescents éparpillés
aux quatre coins du monde
le tim hardin a même été tirées et est
tirée depuis janvier 2016 au format
papier avec un tirage à 15 mille
exemplaires une diffusion dans 500
points de distribution en normandie avec
la conviction que le papier et le
numérique puissent coexister ensemble
car on voulait faire un peu différent
des autres médias qui aujourd'hui base
du papier justement au numérique on
voulait montrer que l'inversé était
possible et que le numérique pouvait
devenir papier sur c'est aujourd'hui
avec ce magazine il suffit de prendre
votre téléphone portable et de flasher
les pages et elles deviennent tout d'un
coup virtuelle grâce à la réalité
virtuelle
on a réussi à assembler les deux est
notre objectif
ce magazine d'ici cinq ans le premier
magazine culturel francophone
gratuit avec cette particularité qui est
celle d'être entièrement rédigé par des
ados mais me diriez vous le principe
même d'une maison d'édition c'est quand
même de publier des romans est là
souvenez vous de ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure
j'avais commencé à écrire un peu dans
mon coin parallèlement aux grands prix
des lecteurs et je me suis dit il faut
publier quelque chose
alors quoi publier et ben justement le
petit roman j'avais rédigé alors qu'ils
étaient totalement un parfum attention
c'était un 40 pages avec plein d'erreurs
dedans mais je me suis dit autant sauter
sur l'occasion j'avais jamais trouvé
d'éditeur
alors j'ai foncé comme ça trois semaines
plus tard je participe à un petit salon
littéraire dans ma villa roman et à la
fin de la journée je me rends compte que
j'ai vendu 25 exemplaires alors 25
exemplaires c'est absolument ridicule 1
000 1 % des ventes marc levy ou
guillaume musso en une année mais pour
moi ça me paraît c'est quand même énorme
et puis quelqu'un m'a demandé où en est
le tome 3 est ce qu'il va y avoir une
suite
et c'est rare et c'est quelqu'un le pré
commandes même sur internet
et là je me suis dit je vais continuer
malgré le petit échec devant thomas donc
je finis d'écrire ce tome 3 cet homme de
pardon que je publie trois mois plus
tard et le jour de la sortie
tout s'est un petit peu bousculé à vrai
dire j'étais en stage chez france bleu
normandie mon stage de foot de troisième
et puis je devais passer un petit appel
un journaliste local et je me suis pas
rendu compte en fait tous les
journalistes de la rédaction écouté ma
conversation en même temps j'avais été
un peu bête quand même de passer le coup
de téléphone en plein milieu toujours
est il que un journaliste et pme voire
va poser quelques questions un peu
curieux et puis la fin de la journée
j'ai enregistré deux interviews et
c'était parti mais moi qui tu viens
purement les mois les plus intenses de
ma ville mais chaîne tv france 2 kebbell
plus ce europe 1 et j'en passe mais ça
m'a permis de vendre quelques 1500
exemplaires de mes romans
ce qui est assez énorme pour un auteurs
auto édités en france et puis
arrivé à ce stade là je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas essayer de réaliser mon
rêve à savoir être édité par une grande
maison d'édition et là je dois vous
avouer que ça a été un peu compliqué je
me suis pris les portes closes en alors
là des mails incendiant d'être aux
jetons lille c'est nul machin machin
machin
toujours est il que j'ai un peu
abandonné l'idée
et puis un jour au moment où j'ai
justement baisser les bras j'ai fait une
rencontre un peu surprenante
j'étais invité comme tous les ans est la
remise des prix du grand prix des
lecteurs du journal de mickey comme ex
juré
pourquoi c'est drôle j'en ai mimiques et
c'est très sympa toujours nette si
c'était la fnac des ternes et je me
baladais dans les rayons de la librairie
et un coup j'ai vu un monsieur tout seul
et je me dis ce monsieur me dit quelque
chose
alors j'ai checké son visage sur google
et bistrots chercher tout et je me suis
rendu compte que ce monsieur en fait
c'était michel lafon le que le créateur
et le pdg de cette maison d'édition et
que j'avais vu son visage dans une vidéo
de youtube euzenat tous qui avait sorti
son bouquin dans cette maison d'édition
quelques mois plus tôt alors je suis
allé le voir je me suis présentée j'ai
expliqué ce que je faisais etc
et puis d'un air très solennel il m'a
regardée et puis m'a dit appelez moi
demain sur ce je les appelais le
lendemain et il m'a donné rendez vous
une semaine d'après à neuilly sur seine
où je me suis rendu dans son bureau avec
mon père et puis je dois avec cet
échange fut assez fructueux et je suis
très heureux de vous annoncer que
justement mon prochain roman
la suite des aventures et en fait c'est
un nouveau premier tome pour être exact
de ma saga sortira chez cet éditeur dans
exactement neuf jours ici n'ont pas tiré
à 25 exemplaires mais à 9000
donc aujourd'hui je suis assez heureux
de pouvoir dire que je fais partie
justement de ce petit cercle d'auteurs
publié et qui ne sont encore que des
ados car je ne suis pas tout seul nom
n'est bonne trentaine en france il n'y a
pas mal à l'étranger aussi et on on
partage tout cette conviction de donner
envie de lire aux jeunes car après tout
à l'école on nous donne à lire l'odyssée
et le site que vous êtes tous tu lire
ici et je dois vous avouer que ça m'a
plu tout donné envie de dormir
personnellement que le lien mais
justement je pense qu'il faut proposer à
aux jeunes de commencer par la
littérature qu'on trouve en librairie
pour la jeunesse harry potter est un
exemple mais je pense ici aussi à une
game divergentes et j'en passe et
ensuite commencé quand on acquiert un
peu la maturité nécessaire au lycée à
lire des classiques aujourd'hui je dois
je pense pouvoir dire que j'ai toujours
fait confiance aux opportunités qui se
présentaient à moi et que par conséquent
j'ai essayé de créer un peu ma propre
histoire et la jeune influencera jamais
cela que vous ayez 16 ans pour son
ailier 20 30 40 50 ou même plus tant que
vous êtes passionné par ce que vous
faites
tant que la cause que vous vanter ou
semble intéressante semble pertinente
alors il faut saisir ces opportunités et
marcel pro 6 est justement l'audace
réussi à ceux qui peuvent profiter des
occasions alors je n'ai qu'un seul
message ce soir
profitez-en merci beaucoup